[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever
we want man we are nine years let's talk
about eminem
no you promise you won't anymore yeah
but he said whatever i want no whatever
we
want you gotta include us yeah yes okay
so we're talking about d12 we talked
about eminem
for like 15 minutes for you you're
making her win right now
we're still talking about mnf this is
gina
what are you doing about elvis presley
elvis presley yeah elvis presley's sick
i call eminem the elvis presley of our
time because graceland
that's that's where he was i have
nothing to talk about though
you want to talk about eminem then i
accepted you
gotta talk about that why you want to
talk about vegas performed in vegas
he has whose side are you on
i don't have anything else to say
anywhere else in the america states
that you guys will be okay with moving
to a side
from las vegas texas what part of texas
is the woodlands
where's that at that let me tell you
where anaheim was digital
okay so i just typed in top places to
live in the us like top
happy the happiest people in the us with
zero
income taxes the woodlawn okay so the
sound very [ __ ]
it's right next to austin but you don't
have to pay austin prices
oh so it's texas your income tax yes yes
yes so
you don't have the mountains in texas
and it's in like a
it's got like beautiful trees everywhere
it looks like the forest
okay but they have like a concert venue
you can listen to live music they got a
little shopping area is it country music
i don't know mandalas yeah there's a lot
of canals and stuff
um they have basically every house is my
dream house
for like three hundred thousand dollars
and like i'm talking you get a view of
like the canyons and like
you know what's crazy so i've been
looking up houses right
nevada you get like half the price of
california
yeah and texas is even half the prize in
nevada yeah
it's crazy i have both on my redfin i
have las vegas
houses popping up and i have the
woodlands houses popping up they both
have my dream houses but ones in the
desert
of like 107 degree heat or probably more
right now it's closer to family
45 minute flight or four-hour drive how
come you guys never talk about arizona
that's in arizona it looks hot it sounds
hot
are you sure what are their taxes like
what are they that's all we kill about
that what's the math
less than zero i think it's i think it's
good they pay you for them
alaska they do they pay you to chiller
i'm down to go to anchorage i don't talk
about arizona
because i don't have any ties there i
like tuscany
ties to any other other so nevada is
gone arizona
so nevada i've i've been going there
like every other year
you know since my whole childhood so i'm
pretty familiar with second home
it's like a second california to a lot
of california people
um and if i need to my my my
dad gets sick i can fly at him really
quickly
or i could drive to him so that's pretty
quick texas i know at least in houston
is a giant asian population
very similar to the 626 so that's
already home to me
so i'm like okay cool if it's close
enter the cool kind of asian too because
they've been amazing yeah they're way
better than the ones out here this one's
stuck out here sure what what's wrong
with the ones without here
like well these are kind of they don't
party as hard they don't party as hard
because it's like
like the the asians that me and joe like
to be we're
rebellious for la asians
because everyone's all [ __ ] all
preppy and [ __ ] you talk about arcadia
asians they're all contained right
oh i know they're gonna be orange and
then we went to houston we're like
everyone's like us you guys weren't
turning up as much as they were i love
houston they're crazy so yeah so that's
why that's my connection
to texas and then also hawaii but they
do have income tax
yeah hawaii is too expensive so the
pandemic changed things for me because
before i was like well california i love
everything about it like i grew up here
the beach is right here everything's
here
but i can't go anywhere you're stuck in
your house like most of the time
so i'm like well if i'm gonna be stuck
in my house this time i might as well be
in my dream house might as well be a big
[ __ ]
cost yeah i've been going out i've been
going out there
you know i've been going to the beach a
lot me too i've been going to the beach
i could go to the mountains i'd be going
to other mountains would you go to texas
hell yeah i would how are you going all
these beaches and mountains and saying
you're so productive
how do i stay productive well yeah but
you say like i'm so productive all the
time i'm getting so much work done but
then you're also like
i'm going to the beaches and mountains
all the time i finished workout one
i wake up at six yeah sometimes i just
don't do work at all
it's like there's that one too he's
gonna say as a non-californian
oh right non-native the only non-native
californian basically
and texan right you too you too yeah
yeah i'm not i'm not native
what where wait you said barbara oh i
think you said non-l.a
different kind of council in california
so my dad was
grew up in carson yeah so she's a real
californian local
as a non-californian i would say
i wouldn't trade the weather here for
anything else that's what i was telling
people i'm like
[ __ ] texas way too [ __ ] right now
there's a freaking heat wave going on
yeah but
it's not all the time we have you really
care about the weather because do you
like
or you do stay outside a lot oh now that
i have a [ __ ] backyard
[ __ ] yeah i am cause like to me ac is
like
ac right so like i've been to asia
in the summer and if i'm a homebody i'm
like then it doesn't make a difference
because just ac is just ac everywhere
but like we could drive 30 minutes here
and then the beach
but you could drive and what if you
lived on a lake that's kind of tight
but the thing is too what what is humid
here is not
actually humid though you know what i
mean like it's like when you say you
have mosquitoes you have mosquito
zappers you can't breathe over there
but over there like when you say you
have mosquitoes mosquitoes are on
youtube talk about texas
yeah in texas yeah like when it's humid
it's [ __ ] humid all right
it's dry yeah it's dry in vegas east
coast there's nobody
i can't live there anymore they make the
beach in vegas they just build a beach
true there's 20 000 homeless people that
lives inside the underground
but we live right now they live above
ground
they live next door actually yeah i'd
rather have that
i'd rather have them in tunnels right
gio
like let's keep them under there where
it's out of sight out of mind let's dig
tunnels in l.a we gotta dig out here
yeah hear me you know what i'm saying
and i was talking to you about
[ __ ] up she was good she brought up a
good point where so i kind of like you i
grew up
like going to the beach all the time and
then she was so up to me i'm like i
would love to live next to the beach but
then she was like but the beaches here
kind of suck
and i'm like what's in relation to like
being in a hawaii type beach in here and
she's like
honestly like santa monica hunting a
beach or any of those beaches it's like
a three out of the ten
oh my damn that's true yeah i really
want beach i don't have a beef then i'll
just go i'll go to hawaii like two or
three times yeah
plus you have to drive so far you have
to drive so far not if you live close
joe wants to move right now so i grew up
in santa barbara we are on the beach
like anywhere you live
you're five minutes maximum away from
the beach i used to live
pretty close to the beach well here it's
like it's different but
yeah out here we're an hour away
freaking five freeways
oh god i kind of like where i'm at
because i'm an
hour away from mountain biking and i'm
an hour away from the beach
and then if i was one or the other i'll
be two hours away
true yeah but at least i have access and
options
sure i love the options here you have
all sorts of terrain you have [ __ ]
desert you have the ocean you got the
beach you got the mountains you also
have the option of federal tax or
option of income but that's that's the
price you pay
so that's the price to pay for this
percent
rich i feel like i feel like boredom is
going to happen no matter what
so it's interest to keep things
interesting you should just constantly
move
that's true like live here ten years
late or five years that was always my
plan
is like we can't do that with a kid now
damn that sucks
yeah don't have kids well now that
everything's homeschooled anyway
or like however long the pandemic is we
don't know but like
how you know school districts are i
don't know are they are they as relevant
now that
everyone's just homeschooling true
that's a good point but then at the
at the same time the kid themselves will
want to have friends
so if you're constantly moving every
year or something [ __ ] them they're
gonna
not they're gonna be a very just
satisfied oh yeah you'll end up like
steve yeah you need that stability i
don't want steve i don't want steve
what's wrong with steve what's wrong
with
you yeah attachment issues he's pretty
self i have attachment issues too
i've moved like every three or five
years my whole life
yeah yeah yeah i don't want this i
didn't move that much and i have
attachment issues
attachment i think everybody has a
little bit of attachment issues yeah
what is the definition of attachment
issues do you have it
you don't you can't attach or you attach
too much i don't know it just sounds
like an attachment style
yeah it's like you're too clingy or
you're dread completely you dread the
people leaving you so you try to leave
them first kind of thing
but that's not quite that's not quite my
version of it my version is more like
um i i moved away from my friends a
couple times as a kid
so i always feel like i could lose my
friends really quickly
oh you better appreciate it i do
i twice told you guys before the
pandemic happened i remember
sitting right there in that chair and
saying man we don't know how long
we we could do this i was during an
episode yeah i'm like i just appreciate
all you guys does all this talk about
moving to
vegas then give you anxiety about your
friends leaving yes
oh [ __ ] but but it's good it's good
because because we're talking about it
together we all want to do it together
that's what i love about it and he has
some friends there already
yeah and you can make new friends all
right i can't make more even a
cul-de-sac
no more new friends i agree actually i'm
kind of over it
no more news new friends i'm making new
ones you're making new ones i'm too
tired for friends
you're making how's your mushroom farm
my washroom farm's cool he's a new
friend
and a new business partner you know
what's my new friend my ass
and that's why i like to take care of my
ass because today's video is brought to
you by
hellotushy.com baby
hi so it's hard to believe when we go to
the bathroom in this country most of us
wipe
instead of wash because uh why is it
hard to believe
sorry because a lot of people let me
tell you this in this country
people aren't used to getting water in
their booty hole they're like what the
hell is that
but after i went to japan i became a
believer because at the cleanest
butthole the whole trip there that when
we came back
we have bidets installed in every single
one of our restrooms so if you guys want
clean buttholes just like me and it
feels really really good
it does but for sure but for a while
though like a lot of us didn't get it
because it's
the days are pretty freaking expensive
yeah it's
it's just not worth it you know just to
like for your booty hole
but then if you really really want a
clean butthole i think
there is a more affordable option and
hellotushy.com
got your back it's only 79 and if you go
to hellotutor.com and use our code off
the record
you get ten percent off so it's even
cheaper than 79 dollars isn't that crazy
yup
like eight dollars off that's 10 off so
hellotushy.com
off the record get your 10
off baby happy birthday especially
when you have diarrhea and you go like
five times and you keep wiping your ass
you have that bloody butthole you look
at the toilet paper
why is it red guess what you don't get
that when you get a bidet because it
cleans your butthole nicely
take a look at your diet too you know
what that is
you know what i've been wanting to do
and this has just been my thing for like
the last
yes are you gonna give us options to
guess this will be fine
oh go ahead okay are we gonna get a clue
no you wanted a guest
bike riding going to the mountains
owning a country dick being a dictator
having a mud hut
going to the living style situation
living style topic that we were in
i thought
i legit always wanted to uh sleep over
in a mall or like the camping section of
rei or something and just stay there
now he's so sick or walmart or whatever
you can't guess
you're too well okay so i don't think my
dreams are that
wild right but i do want to live
part-time
all over the world but i'm always stuck
between like
this routine that we have of meeting and
like
having this thing going on but then um
if i wanted to be lost in the sauce in a
different universe
like let's say if i i just want to live
in thailand for three months yeah
um it's it's difficult with the
lifestyle that we have but it's
more easier now than before because we
get lost for 10 days now
yes whereas before it was like we're
meeting every week yeah and then we're
just constantly on
so thanks to this pandemic now i'm
able to see that i can live the life
that i want way
earlier than i thought like this would
be my retirement life like have you read
the book 40
4 hour work week yes i did and then what
i realized was although efficiency is
good
you lose the quality of a lot of things
by doing it that way
really yeah his is all about huh
because this is all about like only
checking only like working like four
hours
right well i kind of met in the middle
because technically
i work seven days and that take care is
my whole entire month
yeah he's also about being the most
efficient and then
almost like minimum work maximum result
yeah but the problem is
since you don't put heart into things
you can feel that there's no heart in
the product well his thing is about
putting heart into the things he wants
to put heart into like
like you were talking about when we were
talking about retirement and stuff yeah
like
so his he's passionate about traveling
about
like doing like windsurfing and
parachuting all that stuff so beating up
chinese people
yeah that's normal no no he didn't
accuse the kickboxer in china he's doing
a kickboxing thing
right and then yeah and he cut like he
was talking he became the number one
he was like he's like i can't definitely
can't beat up a guy that's been training
for 10 years
but i can cut 50 pounds in a day so he
was like a 200 pound guy and he's
beating up 150 pound chinese guy he's
like i won the championship so his whole
thing is to
game the system and efficiency that's
what i got from that
we all read it and then we all did it
but then
um i think there's a balance behind it
but yeah i met in the middle and then
i worked seven days ish and then i get
my whole month's worth of income yeah it
reminded me of that the way you want to
travel everywhere
and and also because this whole thing is
like taking mini retirements instead of
saving your whole life to
retire at 65 and and starting your life
then is to take
little mini retirements a few times a
year where you're like taking six weeks
and living somewhere else or
or even a couple months somewhere living
somewhere else
um yeah which is really cool and then
like having basically making your whole
work life mobile so that you're able to
do that and like having virtual
assistants and blah blah
but it reminded me of that because you
want to live everywhere and also the tax
wise i just thought about
um i have this one friend that he only
lives
at his house um one month out of the
year because if you're
gone out of the u.s 11 months out of the
year you don't pay federal taxes
oh holy [ __ ] this guy's crazy yeah
i don't think i could do that but riddle
me this what if we combine our jk
shoot days into one week out of the
month
it's like six days total then you can be
gone for three weeks you take three
weeks
that'd be sick if you guys want to do
that i'm down but then you wouldn't
really be up to date on news
because you'd be like a monkey needing
to be up to date with news
when will we ever be up to date i kind
of like the that would make it worse if
we did the whole one week
i kind of like where it's at right now
because i get to see
this like this is kind of a cool routine
that we have where
it doesn't even feel like work we just
get to yeah catch up hanging out too
yeah yeah but then now i can explore all
the things that i've always wanted to
for a very very long time but i think
that the next stage is going to be me
um living like in japan for a year or
europe for a year or
somewhere where i get to be completely
lost in a whole different world
because when i'm getting tastes of these
like in vietnam and all that stuff
it's mind-blowingly good for me i feel
like a hippie that needs to find himself
in india
nice you should would you ever do
ayahuasca
maybe literally reborn yourself i want
to do it i would
i'm not like i'm not like curious enough
to go
i gotta [ __ ] do that so when i have
that feeling i probably will
but right now i think i'm more excited
by going
i just want to live here and be absorbed
into that
for a minute yep how real is vegas to
you guys
pretty real you always feel about vegas
well what's that's tight if out of a
scale of
one through ten ten is we're moving next
month
what's the what's the scale oh i think
it's just hard to
say that because we have like brick and
mortar business
um that have employees and stuff and i
think just planning that
is pretty rough um but if we had that
all situated i think i could move in a
month
whoa move that move barbell into vegas
oh yeah
that and then just making sure that my
family's on board i guess the biggest
thing is that yeah
who do you have to convince i'll help
you your mom your brother
they knocked that down okay so is it
because your mom helps with taika
well and just because i'm uh she's my
mama and i want her okay because there's
like two different parts because i was
like
if we had a little community we could
all take care of each other's kids
i'm not gonna move to vegas but i want a
reason to go gamble
and visit you guys perfect we'll be
there man i think i think
i'll probably skip you guys and go to
the casino yeah i'll be out of town when
you come i know we're just gonna be like
we'll just see
joey here he was like instagram because
i'm in vegas i'm like what the [ __ ] you
didn't even call me
i'll know cause i'll be playing [ __ ]
crafts with this guy for
a dollar we'll be there with [ __ ]
hazmat suits and masks
and then like playing craps and high
fives and hell yeah dude it's crazy
sometimes i wake up in the morning and
he's in my pool and i'm like what the
[ __ ] how did this happen
i wouldn't be surprised if that should
happen that's true i'd be coming over
swimming and then he leaves because i
just barged your towel
and he throws on the floor i can picture
all of it
i'm surprised i haven't been shot yet
one day i was just chilling on
in bart's backyard on his chair and he
hasn't even woken up yet
and i was just on the phone and i turn
around he goes how long have you been
waiting there for her
that's amazing i didn't know that joe
was here
yet yeah so i was just like kind of
looking out the front window i was like
oh this one's just coming
i don't know i turn around i'm like what
the [ __ ] is it right there
so that's when i went funny we didn't
see his car
no usually uh like the car would drive
by and then like we'll get a
notification on our camera
you know show up on my phone we just did
it oh [ __ ] so i didn't even know he was
there
yeah where do you get off barging in
people's backyards and chilling
okay i want to use this pool and he's
welcome too
tight can i do that no can we all no
just show oh i just dropped it okay
we're all asked every week
i'm going to ask you everything okay
just come with me
okay if you if you come with joe you
can't yeah i've gotta
you guys gotta be there at six in the
morning
one other thing i want to try is van
life
yes i think tycho would [ __ ] love it
dude if it wasn't for this guy really
you would do a van life
oh yeah what's wrong with my family i
can't take a there's a shower
in there oh then i'm in see it's not
like the kind you want a jerry shower
it's not hot it's a rinse it's a real i
don't give a [ __ ] you don't care
do that but if you need to be able to
take a shower you open it and you go
oh there's a lake right there yeah i'm
in that sounds sick
i love it i just need to take a shower
that's it
[Music]
you